is my cavum normal I think I'm gonna rip
some hair out there oh oh oh look at
that that pink squiggly thing that's a
mold of my middle ear before I tell you
why I'm holding my ear let's get one
thing straight none of this would be
happening if it weren't for Neil
Armstrong back in the 1960s plantronics
got its start building headsets for
pilots they even built the first headset
worn on the moon by the 1990s they were
building headsets for you and me which
brings me to my ear in the last 15 years
plantronics has taken more than a
thousand casts of different ears after
measurements have been taken designers
use the raw data to build prototypes
that will fit the most number of years
and sometimes they even keep these molds
at their desks now collecting ear data
sounds simple but making an accurate
mold is pretty challenging especially if
you're the one getting silicone pumped
into your ear canal so I'm going to put
a little cotton block down into your ear
canal just a few millimeters down and
what this will do is protect your
eardrum it will keep the material from
going too deep in the ear what so one
thing I didn't even think of but it
seems very obvious is that I can't
actually hear anything right now yes
you'll have to hear through the other
ear which I have to talk a little louder
yeah we gotta fill atop this yeah that's
this pillow talk so one of the most
important points of data that you pull
from the ear we might consider for
example the year length that your width
where you fit the earbud the area where
you fit your buds normally like your
iPod earbuds there's a specific area
there that we know very well their
geometry in the sizes well they actually
come in here and take headsets at their
building and prototypes and put them
into the ears and and do those basics
kind of those yeah if you go visit our
design center you'll see that there are
many ear molds at the designers desk
generally a small and medium and a large
so that they can make sure that their
design accommodates all of the
population would it be safe to say that
ears are a lot like fingerprints I'd say
no two ears are alike yeah like
snowflakes and fingerprints yeah just
when I was starting to wonder whether
putting all that goo in my ear was worth
it my ear actually arrived in the mail
and it turns out my beautiful cabin is
actually pretty average which means that
plantronics designers are going to be
Stefan a whole lot of prototypes in this
year
oh that's a weird sound oh and I almost
forgot the best part I can finally lick
the inside of my own ear